okay
oh
all right
um so something else that i've done is
that i have this um
uh
screen key set up so that whenever i'm
typing you can see what i'm typing
and so
uh awesome all right i can see when if
people are typing the discord chat i
have that on my phone right next to me i
also have my very trusty um
dispatch
as a plushie so i'll be using that as
well for confidence during these trying
times
um
so what is a rebel let's get started
there that's easy so rebel
here's your classic rebel right
um the julie rebel means uh read
evaluate print loop so it's going to
read whatever you type in
right
so i just type three plus three and you
should be able to see me typing those
are the keys that i typed and i'm gonna
be doing a couple of key combinations
and shortcuts so i'm hoping that people
can um really get so for example there
you saw that i zoomed in with control
plus right and if i press enter that's
the enter key and so julia read this
um
then i entered then it printed that and
now it's asking me again so it's in a
loop right that's easy enough uh big key
combo control plus l clears your screen
so i'm just gonna be going through many
of these please feel free to ask your
questions
um
and so we're gonna go over the very
basics right so
the basic flow is that you're going to
be defining stuff here in your apple
right
could you move your webcam overlay i can
um yes i think
i think
um peter i believe
the sound is from your end yes
um
how do i
hello
yeah philippos has sound so we should be
good
um
i don't know how i can move this overlay
remove from stream
not from there
edit audio avatar edit name stop my cam
uh this might be a stream yard thing
um
i'll just try not to go on the bottom
right corner
how about that
um
there's a layout button stream yet you
just have to be to the left of the
screen i think it's to the left of the
one you have select now
so it's two to the one you have selected
now
so it could be that one
but
i don't know that that's better rachel
um
i don't know that people nearly have
shift press
picture and picture layout
um
oops that's not the one yeah all right
um
how about this we can try
just doing a full-on rebel experience
and if people i'll drop in for questions
or when i really want to connect with
people face to face
um
so yeah this is
um
this is your julia ripple you're going
to be defining stuff here
so we're going to find functions right
oh no that's not what i wanted
so we can do a square and i'll say oh
you defined function square
and then you can do square is three and
enter and you get nine back awesome
so
what's really cool about this is that
you are going to
um
be able to define all sorts of functions
and workflows and then you'll be able to
calculate stuff that interests you or
you will you'll be able to see
um pictures or you'll you'll be able to
download stuff so
you don't
getting
into the mindset of
almost everything i need to do with
julia i can reach for with the ripple is
part of the message of today's talk and
making you as comfortable and as
powerful as you can be with this tool at
your fingertips is the overarching thing
like that that is what we want for you
to do today so there's a couple things
that a lot of people don't know how to
do or haven't seen before so we're going
to go over a lot of them
um but first we're going to talk about
julian mode so the ripple comes with
four modes julie mode rebel mode packet
uh to the middle package mode help mode
shell mode we're gonna talk right now
about julian mode right two mode is this
one where you just evaluate stuff and
then you're like all right x was six or
something
and um
i don't know you can do base that
summary size of x and i'll say it's
eight bytes or something
all right
um
yeah no questions instead of getting the
sound visuals when you mean what did the
first episode work and what they didn't
mean the one you didn't intend
um i don't remember i typed that in a
while ago
uh so something cool is that
so i just evaluated um the size and it
gave me eight so if i ever want to
calculate stuff
with the latest value that i ever
defined in the rebel there's this
keyword called ants so when you're
running in rebel mode anz is bound to
the last thing you ever evaluated at so
it's like persistent until you actually
evaluate something else so i could
technically do something like ants to
the that and then ants
um
two ants and that should be 80
yes
right and now if i do ants
squared
then that's going to be
i don't know 80 squared right and this
is very useful this will really save
your bacon if you're doing some long
computations and you don't want to retry
it again and you're like oh right i can
just do like
temp equals ants and now i have my temp
variable so that's something useful
um
all right
um
and that's about as powerful as a rebel
as you get in other languages like
they're just there's just isn't that
much of an
investment i've tried to be scientific
about them and we'll talk about a little
spreadsheet that i have for different
other languages
um
so
now
we're going to be trying to work the
best that we can with different sorts of
uh functionality that julian mode offers
and this is going to mean basic
navigation right so this will be the way
the equivalent of doing musical skills
on a piano so get ready
um
also a reminder github will now let you
just hover over this and click copied so
you can just jump onto your apple and
type in that
right
so what's cool is that you can do
something
that's very useful
which is
um
you can
first of all you can quit your apple
right with ctrl d
um so whenever you're like i bork my
rebel that's not a good thing you can
just abort with d
um
and then you can also do control c when
something is stuck
and you can clear your entire stream
screen with control l this is probably
the thing i will type in the most during
any time that i'm using the rubble it's
just too useful to like go back to the
top of the input for myself
please increase the browser font size
thank you um
this that that was useful i forgot about
that
um
so
let me check that nobody's does someone
have the github repo url i'm gonna run
that again by people
yeah no worries
we are this is a banner
and
we're showing that
yes sir
all right
so we should be good now
um
all
right so if you're ever
evaluating
a
i don't know
uh function i'll show you how i did that
in a second and you ever forget that you
have to
type in like the last
um
return value it's if you just type in
here end that will evaluate the entire
function
but if you do alt enter then you will
and you will get a new line so i didn't
know the alt enter before when i started
and it was very aggravating
um
and so i'm letting you know so that you
don't get as aggravated as i did when i
started out with julia
so there you have it
um
uh thank you rachel for posting in the
discord
um
so the first really powerful thing that
that's useful to know in the rebel is
that you can just type up or down
to go back and forth through your rebel
history
so for example i can go back to when i
defined x
right and then i can just do that with a
bunch of up arrows right i did it with
11 papers
but something that people might not know
is that when you scroll up into that
history entry you can also type in down
and that will go down from
that entry itself right so now i can
just
replay my history if i keep pressing
down and enter and that's something
really really useful right because if
you ever try to write down a
presentation what you should do is you
just have an entire script
you copy paste it into the ripple and
then you can add in a comment like
start
presentation
right and then you do alt enter right to
get a new line and you're like x equals
three
and then you can do
you can just go
way back up to where that start
presentation line was
all right
so
something that people might not also
know
is that
your up arrows and down arrows are smart
in the sense that if i ever type in
function
and then if i type in let's say funk
and then i press the up arrow
this pulls up the latest entry in my
history that matches up to funk
right
so this is really cool because you can
like leave like little book like you
just have to memorize little bookmarks
to where you need to
like if i just do start and i type up
i'm at the beginning of that
presentation if i'm trying to remember
oh my god what was that last time i
called that really funky function
in
bass was called bass uh and then i just
type up i just type up and that will
auto complete in my ripple search like
in the history that i've input into the
rebel right
so
that is extremely useful right if you're
ever typing
your very long complicated functions
once again you do
function hamming or you just get you
just remember there was ham or something
so you do function
ham
and then bam
that's the
latest that you can get all right i'm
gonna field some questions here for a
second
um
[Music]
comments
uh what's the alt enter on a mac i just
tried everything me neither does any
does anything like alt enter work for
mac wasn't able to figure it out it's
alt shift enters on windows yes thank
you
um
fitzner because it's
some of these
there's some inevitable
per operating system configurations that
we can't get around um we're going to
talk a little bit more about that
what's the thing you're using to print
out your keystrokes that looks very
useful no that's an entirely reasonable
question graham it's called screen keys
um let me post it
here i just installed it via ubuntu
um it's called screen
keys you can just do like straight up
um sudo apt install for screen keys
um
all right so
now we're going to do a little bit of
exercise movements
um
so
oh my god that's horrible
horrible print but
this is supposed to be
a snake
and what you can do is you can
just
use the arrows
to move around
through the snake oops screw that up oh
no my snake is dead or my snake is
deformed and then try and get to the
apple right
so you can do that with the with the
arrow keys
but
there's other ways to move around and
we're going to talk about a few of them
right actually that should be with a
um
comma so i'm gonna show off a little bit
of um i'm gonna i'm gonna show off
something but i'm gonna explain it later
so you can pull up a shell
enter into your editor and then go snick
right and then i can do
like that
correct it and then get
um
do that
commit
let's
go
with
fix right good push origin
so we're going to talk a little bit more
about that particular workflow but the
point is if i ever want to do a quick
fix onto a typo i can do that within i
don't know 20 seconds with my ripple um
let's go back to
the hungry hungry snake
so what we can do is actually there's a
couple more
um
this poor snake
is
oh
is also deformed
there we go
um
snake typos right good push
so we're going to talk everything about
how i just did that those things right
but for now just believe me that there's
a snake
no snake
there you go snake oh it's because i
have the comment before that
um
and
this
should have oh no
there we go so all right snake is no
longer dismembered
and so what we're gonna do is
we could use the arrow keys but we can
also learn a couple of useful uh key
bindings right so if you start at where
the snake is
there's the controls for moving forward
which is via
control f
and then you can also move down with
control so think of it as control
forward then you can move down with
control n
and then you can move forward again
control n would be like control next
line
control p will move you to the previous
line
and then control forward
oh no that was to the end
but i can move backwards with control b
right so i can move
around the snake forward four far
forward
uh and then for forward and then next
next next next all right so there's some
hijinks about like when it does or
doesn't like go back a character or not
but the point is you can also move
around with those keys and so this is
going to be useful when we don't want to
take our hands off the home row
we're going to build up to that but i
just want to let you know
there's ways that you can move the
cursor around without needing to go to
the arrow keys and you can change that
and we're going to look at
that in a bit
all right question
so
people should be seeing the updated
snake now
because i pushed that change yay
awesome so snake is no longer
dismembered and just github has the
worst rendering there um
so one of the cool things that you can
do now is without uh removing your hands
from the keyboard you can do function
and then control p
right so you don't need to go down to
the arrow keys so you can just do oh
what was the last function that i
defined
right and so you can you just need
control p and control n
right
so
and you can go um back and forth in your
history with control p and control n so
i find that um very useful
all right what's next um
you should yeah you should have scrolled
back in time
um
[Music]
also if you like this if you like that
trick for finding the most recent
history item in your
in your rebel please spam me on twitter
and or the julie chat with your favorite
emoji just that i know how many people
are actually
feeling going along with the tutorial
right now because
seeing people type their favorite emojis
makes me chuckle quite a bit and it's
also a great way we're going to learn
how to type emojis this is not a proper
julie tutorial if we don't go through
auto completing emojis right
um so all right we saw like just one
moving one character at a time but
there's definitely easier ways to move
more than that and there's a couple of
ways that it's delimited by backspace so
there's this key called meta which
people should also have access to
and you can do
so i'm going to do control p control p
and then
move backwards but i can also do meta
backwards right
and so this one goes back through
um white space right so it's going
through all the white space so i'm going
backwards or forwards through all the
backspace
which i kind of think of as going
through words or like terms
at a time so you can just do like oh
yeah right so it's quite a bit faster
than just going via just pure
uh control forwards or control backwards
you can just do
meta backwards or you can do
like i can go all the way up here and
then do
um
meta forwards
oh no not that don't want that
uh
meta forward there we go
so i can go
down four lines and then
matter backwards right
so if you're
uh the point is to try and practice
going around the snake
with
the
via the corners of the snake
right so this is going to be
meta forwards
go down all the way
and then
meta backwards
and then
go up here and then
meta forward meta forward forward
forward
down again
and then
there we go right
we can go around the snake in
different ways
awesome um oh no there you go
question so far
um
all right good vibes why these hotkeys
are not compliant with the vim defaults
we're going to talk about them defaults
i love them defaults we're not getting
those here
right now but they start out with
emacs defaults and
until people pull requests differently
and big shout out to
um
john in the chat
who is
posted their
vimbinix.jl
and there's one by caleb allen two
so they're in the they're in the discord
um
all right so also very useful if you're
at the very end of your input and you
want to go all the way back you can just
type home
or you can type end
so if you ever have a huge function
and you don't want to type it all again
or you have a really long one-liner you
can just type
home and end
right or you can do
you can do meta at sorry
that was
yeah that's supposed to be all right
it's supposed to be control at the
beginning
and then control end
so that will take it to the end of the
line but if you type it at the end of
the line it will take you
to the end of the input right
once again
if i have my cursor at the end i can do
control a to get to the very beginning
i can scroll down
ctrl end to go to the end of the line
um ctrl a to go to the beginning of the
line
ctrl end
ctrl a
and then if you type both of those
really quick
then you go back to the beginning of the
input right
so ctrl a control e
um
so now it's
very you we've tried
we're getting comfortable with the
ripple
um
what
we can move around now with the basics
we're gonna go over a bit more movement
uh keys in a bit
but it's useful to know what are other
stuff what are things that are already
defined for you in the rebel or stuff
you've defined so we're getting into
more navigating what you've done now
and part of that is using functions like
var info
right so var info will include
uh stuff you've defined
uh how much they way in memory
and the summary right so this says that
i've defined this surprise thing
um
i this ants interactive utils
core base and main
main and bass are
whenever you start a julia rebel session
they're going to be defined for you core
is stuff that julie needs for starting
out like
and so we're not going to worry about it
it's very intrin internals related stuff
very finicky don't need to worry about
that
um
and
what is
useful is you know trying to figure out
the difference between these two things
and so i try to do
a little demo of that
also you can copy paste into the rebel
but you can
also try that and then if i want to pull
up my
base
some and then remember if you want to go
back just ctrl p
and
you do that
to ask and you can see the difference
with var and then instead of typing the
whole thing i do control p
because wow why is why did that happen
oh my god
so i'm gonna reduce the font size
and
there we go that was weird oh it's
because of this weird type signature
that everything got wrapped worked with
the printing
um
right so a is 48 bytes b is
a lot more bytes and it's because one of
them is a step range right so once again
i type a and i do control p
oh sorry um this is i find this very
useful when you remember the name of
variable but not how you define it you
just do a equals and then control
p
hello
oh did i skip a
all right i think i didn't do it then
what is wrong
[Music]
all right weird
it maybe my copy got
um
i think the
copy pasting somehow broke the wrap
that was interesting
at any rate you can do a equals and then
control p and you'll auto complete the
how you define the variable so i find
that really useful sometimes and then
when i'm done with seeing how it was
defined i'll just do home and then
comment it out so i know that it doesn't
bork the rest of my code so it's just i
just have it accessible
um
another really useful combination is
that uh first of all i'm not coming up
with all these combinations they're all
in the manual and reading the manual is
something that at some point everyone
should do at least the julie rebel part
it's very friendly um what's not so
friendly is that there's just this long
list
of so well we're going to talk about
package mode and shell mode and all this
stuff
there's this long list of key bindings
and they're explaining the same thing
i'm explaining to you but with very few
examples if any it's supposed to be like
a reference and so the part of this in
part this tutorial is to try and
have some useful
um
examples that people can work themselves
up to that level of proficiency where
they're just like all right yeah that
means
this thing so
one of the useful
key bindings that you can do when you're
just starting a repel if you're
debugging something that keeps airing or
something doesn't load or you start
restarting
um
the jewelry replicas you can just do a
control
ah
you can just you can do ah sorry that's
meta
right
you can do meta and then the
less than right so that will
take you back to the
first thing you define in this julius
session
on the other hand if you type in
um
alt and then greater than that will
give you the last entry in this rebel
session right so
that should have worked
oop
all right for some reason that doesn't
work for me but you should be able to
get the last thing that you entered in
this julius rebel session we're going to
talk a little bit about how julie rebel
history works we're going to look at it
and so you're going to see that it's not
that hard to parse yourself and we're
going to see a couple packages that do
that one of mine included maybe
um
so small little exercise for people if
you have
um
that's another thing that i need to fix
so that it doesn't print because that's
not useful
right so there's a couple of mushrooms
here that we should definitely delete
and so one of the things one of the
keystrokes that you can do is a matter
backspace so you can do
alt delete
and then you can do control to hover
over word and then delete again
so
that's
how you can really quickly get rid of
all the mushrooms right so let's add
that
um
badger
um this is control plus
right
and then
control plus left
skip over an entire word
and then that
[Music]
um
control
[Music]
plus left
silence badger
right
push origin main awesome and then you
can buffer the control l and that will
auto delete so if we do words
once again that's how it ended up
and
another word to do another let's do that
again because why not
oh no
there we go
so that's the
that's the input and so you can just do
what i end up doing is control delete
also works so i'll just go back like all
right um beginning
oh sorry alt
and then
alt delete control to skip over
and then alt delete control to skip over
i'll delete
and so that will
you can quickly work your way around
with just control and the keys and you
can delete
i find that very ergonomic so i'm going
to read the chat for questions now
um
uh
[Music]
you can also do control a for home
control a gets you to the beginning of
line home for the beginning of the entry
is there a library for tui there are
we're going to talk about a few of them
um chance when should we preference
using the rebel id or plain script um
basically every full-fledged ide has
rebel integration vs code has it too
um so there's definitely gonna be talks
on vs code
go to the talks on vs code they're gonna
talk to you about what the repo is um
alin the repo is what you're looking at
now it's like the julia terminal read
evaluate print loop that's what repple
stands for is everyone's struggling and
when someone's trying to find some of
these modifier keys on the mac i'm very
sorry for the mac users
inside the ide um so i'm focusing on the
ripple because different ides have
different
levels of support for everything that
you can do in the rebel and some of the
shortcuts can be hijacked by the editor
so
or you need to type in a combo of two
but this is
the most
basic julie experience no matter where
you're using julia
almost
i think pluto and jupiter definitely
have this emacs has a lot of this but
sometimes it struggles with clearing
screen
vs code is probably the best support of
rebel at the moment
um
yeah
all right
yeah me too sorry for the mac users
um all right there's a spur used to do
here
which i will try to get to
so i'll do
um alt to get back
and then i can do
meta word nope
i can do
metad
yeah to delete the word in front of me
so if you're used to the
oh that's much faster than what i used
to do
so oh
i deleted a
thing here
so
oh so if i go back to the badger
mushrooms i can just do
um ctrl f
and ctrl b to move around i mean alt b
and c
alt f to move around and then i can do
alt
d to delete an entire word oh that's
neat all right learn something every day
and so yeah i don't even need to
reach for the backspace key so if you
try this alt dfb combo you can really
move around quite quickly and just
delete stuff that needs to be deleted
all right
um
let's try that uh there's another key
for deleting stuff and that's ctrl w
so let's try that one
um clearly doesn't work
um home to get to the front
control end
to get back nope i want back back nope i
want
at the beginning of this input right and
now if i do control w
oh sorry this one's backwards right
if i do
if i go forwards with alt
and then i do
control backwards control w it will
delete backwards until the first
instance of white space
right
so once again
if i'm
here
and i do control w i can delete
the first thing that
isn't white space
i i delete up to the first thing that is
white space i'm sorry
so if i do that
and then i do
control sorry it's
ctrl a to get at the beginning of the
line
um i didn't want to go back that far so
i'll just go to the front of this word
and then i can do ctrl w then that will
be
enough right
so ctrl w can help you delete backwards
up until white space
um
you can also do ctrl right and ctrl f
for going around yeah just wanted to
make sure i had that written in
um
all right
how to send all the code of ripple
session to a file
we're going to talk about a way to do
that
in fact if you use dr dock strings there
i made a function specifically for that
to copying stuff until your clipboard
but it's not too hard
um
all right so we're gonna do something
that's kind of funky
um and people
might have to set up some config so just
bear with me for a second
um
there's this macro called edit
we're going to talk about in a second
but unfortunately if you use it on
another macro it won't work
and you'll get this nasty stack trace so
a stack trace means that your function
so the function that you started with
right the rebel scope called another
function edit which is you know
what this wrap macro is wrapping
which calls a function location which
calls the which function
so the nesting of the functions goes up
until you hit the error right something
happened here in which which
then through an error
if you want to go on to
line set into
function seven
what you can do just after the stack
trace has been thrown is you can type
seven
and then control q
and so oh my god
that does not exist
uh control exit
let's try a different one we get a stack
trace we type in two
and then ctrl q
and so this will show you
this will pull up your predefined editor
actually this is a really good teachable
moment this will show you your
predefined editor and it will jump into
the line that was involved in that stack
trace so if you've never seen this
before this is a really this is a funky
editor that comes in with a bunch of
linuxes it's called nano and it says
error no unique method matching for
unspecified specified argument types so
this happened to me before and i was
like that was not fun i don't like nano
i haven't used it in years let's look at
what you can actually do
to
jump in with your editor of choice right
so you can define this variable called
env julia editor
and as a string add in your own path
right
oh
oh right because
oh my rebel sometimes autocompletes the
brackets
right
so now that the julia editor yeah i'm
going to talk about clipboard and you
guys are all asking questions that i'm
not being able to answer as quickly as i
want
so now if i define that i should be able
to do
edit
get that horrible stack trace and then
if i do two
control q
then it's going to throw me into vim
right and vim is the thing that i like
for jumping in and out of files really
quickly throwing a quick edit and then
doing uh control q
right
so if you want that to be persistent you
can throw it up on your configuration
file we're going to talk about that
later but just know that there's this
thing that you have to define
so that it can be pulled up by the add
edit macro
so now if you ever want to use at edit
and you're like oh what is a function
we're going to talk a lot about this
function parse one two three
right i wanna see what that thing is i
want to explore all the goodness of
julia you do enter and then this will
throw you
directly into where
that function is defined right like this
this is where
this is the parse function
in julia 1.7.3 share julia bass bars
like this is it this is the thing i
called
so
uh don't be afraid to use atlas you can
also i think you can also configure
um
less
to use not cat
so you can do if you don't want to jump
in with your entire editor you can do
something like
less
right and that will
that one doesn't have colored rendering
i think there's definitely a way
to
um
there's definitely a way to set up um
less with your predefined uh pager
terminal pager we're going to talk more
about that later
um
all right i'm going to field some
questions now
ah thanks so wow this dress analysis is
so awesome i would have saved me so much
time i'm hoping so ronan we're gonna
talk about some cool other stuff
um that you can also do
on my vsco rebel control underscore
works but not control slash i'm sorry
for that um there's a
vs code maintainer so i'm sure they're
going to be able to give you way better
tips than i just did so
what is the thing that one the being
able to jump in and out of your editor
allows you to do um
this is the point you get an error you
jump into the stack trace of your
package you edit your error and then you
rerun your code and this is going to be
exponentially more productive when we
look at revised.jl and how that works
right
we're also going to talk a little bit
about how where you can leave like these
variables saved to your environment in
your julia code there's a file for that
um but before that i just want to let
people know that whenever you see like
those nicely formatted um
um
nicely formatted uh let's say it's
they're not stack traces per se but you
see these numbered
um entries
you can jump into these two so for
example i can type in this is
this is um
this is to parse ipv4 sockets right so
if i type in nine
control q
hello
oh no
uh is it on julian 1.8
maybe it's three
there we go so
for some reason it wasn't working with
the other one but
ideally you should be able to
um
[Music]
wait is this shaking no unique method
much for the unspecified argument types
okay that was this is weird
because i should be able to
do methods
and then jump on this
third one
right this one is for abstract string
ctrl q
and it's saying it's not finding that
all right unfortunate the point is
whenever you see nicely formatted
methods like this you should be able to
jump into that stack trace
um again with the same keyboard shortcut
so one control q
yeah that's the one right okay
still pulling up the latest actors so
maybe i need to maybe i just found a bug
and i need to
um
yeah i think i just found a bug
interesting
all right
um
uh all right
i think that that's a bug
when starting with julia it can feel
very big
so we've seen that you can go into
definitions that you've defined
you can if you know a function
then you can
look it up
but
there's still a lot of stuff
there's a lot of functions inside of
julia inside of the packages that you
import so
it feels like a lot um there's i don't
know like a gajillion functions that are
defined and there's a lot of
funky stuff like parsing or
bootstrapping and compiler stuff you're
not going to learn everything overnight
but you know what's really useful it's
really useful if you could at least know
the stuff that is offered to you or what
is
likely
so there's this thing called auto
completion with tab
right
and autocompletes are amazing and
there's many different kinds of
autocompletes and people don't know the
extent of things that can get auto
completed and i think it's just the
coolest right so you can complete
packages that you have defined so if i
do using lin
tab
it will now import linear algebra but if
i do using
p and then i do tab tab it will auto
complete for all of the packages that i
have in my environment right so i'm like
oh right yeah i'm sure i wanted package
right
um
so
completing packages that works from
within julian mode
if you don't remember the name of a
function you can type in
tab
right
and then i was like oh right that was
tab
and then if i don't even remember the
arguments of a function i can open the
parentheses
type in tab
and then i will have the methods that
are appropriate
also autocompleted
and those auto completions will should
narrow down
as you fill in more types so this should
be
more precise
right
than this
let's try that again i do parse int
space or parse int
i only get three out of completions but
if i don't have any type signatures and
i type in tab i get all the possible
auto completions
right
so people should now be losing it in the
chat
i'm
certain the people should be like oh my
god how is this possible this is amazing
the this this is just the best thing
since sliced bread and toast
all right
so
we should um
i should also
talk about our tab there we go
so
parse
tab
shows all methods
um yeah
narrows to all methods there there we go
we're gonna include that in a bit yeah
so that's the thing where i'm seeing the
head blown emote like mind exploding
emojis now this is exactly what i wanted
um
you can also autocomplete for fields
um
um
yeah so if you don't know what a string
is
you can type in the dot
and then you can type in
tab tab and it will expand to all of the
fields that are defined
in string right so i don't know what is
a hash and i'll be like oh that's that
that's hash for whatever like whatever
that means
and so you can just when i don't know
stuff
in a repo i'll just look at the big
structures that are exported and i'll
just auto complete on them and i'm like
oh
right
flags the string has flags a hash an
instant a layout a name parameter all
right i can i get that
um so i i've defined x
what fields does x have none of them
it's just a number but if i have the x
be an array of one oh my god i hate this
we're going to talk about how to get rid
of that
i can just do x
tab tab no
body no
oh my god
um
[Music]
so array
x equals
array one two three one
[Music]
all right so it's not letting me access
the fields here um
but the point is you can just access oh
let's say
um
io equals i o buffer right i created an
i o buffer and i don't know what's in it
so i'm just going to tap
autocomplete to be like all right
there's an append there's a data there's
a mark max size pointer readable that's
the kind of thing you'd want to know if
you're using a buffer right but if
you've never used it before you're like
oh those are the things that will let
you know
what this buffer thing is right there'll
be a couple of boolean flags set
um
what's this mark
it says -1 that must be important
and now data all right it's empty right
maybe it's some defaults
um
[Music]
another thing that people don't know um
there's this functional so
there's this function called read lines
which will let you
project um let's do
the license
right
so it will spit out the
entirety of the file
as a vector of strings
but what if you don't remember
the name of the file you can do lie and
then tab to autocomplete so you can get
string out of completion on paths
per se when you're operating with
strings and that's just so nice because
you can also do source
tab
and then that will
it will keep auto completing
as you go down the uh folder structure
right
so
i don't know there's not that much there
but the point is that that is feasible
oh my god i already wrote this
um
all right every julia self-respecting
tutorial needs to at some point talk
about the fact that we have a bunch of
unicode support so
if you type in
a alpha
and then tab
it will autocomplete
if you type in beta
it log complete
it's not fine but we can find it
you can also
subscript
so if you do under slash
equals
4
you can now do
um
ah i forgot my syntax there
um
three
and that's 12. awesome
and so you can also keep um completing
for oh what was that thing that was
called like par
you can just do
all right that was um
partial yeah partial
right so you can keep auto completing
even if you don't have the entirety of
your um
unicode symbol memorized right so that's
another really easy way
um
but we also have emojis
so
you can
if you don't remember what the boat
emoji was called
you can do blow
b-o-a oh there's a bore what's a there's
a bore oh my god there's a boar
awesome
so
yeah
arithmetic on emojis
works amazing
um i'm looking at some questions now and
take a strategic sip of water
um
typo narrows instead of narrow ah again
um
oh there's a lot
uh control crew is awesome track tricks
analysis works for me
uh mind blown oh my god amazing i kind
of wish we could temporarily remove the
source of the method it's a lot of
visual noise yes method display there's
a lot of bike [ __ ] going for um back and
forth with that uh
it's not easy to
come up with sensible defaults for that
everyone will like
uh
it's second nature to tab everything
everywhere um
you stumble upon them once you get like
the hang of it but just
keep randomly trying to um auto complete
stuff
i also wish more red bulls implemented
ants yes
you can use methods with
yes
um
[Music]
all the time that was wasted
oh note in python have underscore the
same as ants
interesting i did not know that can you
substitute anything like in latex or
does it have to be a unicode character
representing it in subsequent form it
has to be unicode character
and in fact there's a unicode proposal
about including all the freaking
superscripts and subscripts because for
some reason they don't like them elias
welcome
thanks for coming on
we're going to talk about one of your
packages i think
i'm going to try and show it off
all right i think
arrays don't have fields yeah thanks
peter uh
now
all right um
[Music]
another super useful function um if
you're
autocompleting emojis is um let's say
that you really want your bore
emoji
you can always uh pipe that into the
clipboard function
and now you can just
paste all the boards you've ever wanted
so
there you go
uh the clipboard function
very useful
clipboard we're going to talk about a
little bit about how i just did that
uh last thing that i want to show people
you can do
if you're we're going to talk about the
shell rebel shell mode in a bit but if
you do shell
ls
and then
your home directory uh let's say julia
right and then
tab you can keep auto completing in the
shell mode and this is amazing
right
so you're like config startup oh what's
that
and we're going to talk about that
[Music]
um also note that i what i just did
there
so if i'm in the julian mode but the
last comma the last command that i put
in was in the shell mode and i press up
it will still
go back into shell mode like it doesn't
think that oh i'll go back to your last
julian mode command it goes straight
into the show mode so we're gonna talk a
little bit about what all that means
just um be aware that you can jump
around directories really quickly
because you don't miss out on the um
auto completion that you normally have
in the shell
also
um
kenno shared this on twitter
and you can set up your own
rebel
completions so
you can
type in
instead of so
keno was doing some gnarly gnarly
um
category theory stuff and he really
needed some specialized mathematical
notation so instead of doing partial
over left
um
uh
over left
arrow
yeah tab there we go so instead of
completing all those things
i don't know three
he just said
what if i write
poll
and then that's it oh yeah because i
missed the character
right because he needed a
at any rate um
so you can set up your own rebel auto
completions if you were
writing some specifically mathematical
heavy code you might as well just
use that for the internals and yeah be a
very happy camper
there's a lot more
rebel completions that i've shown here
they're not all of them but they're also
i found them to be particularly useful
when i was like
trying to figure out what all the macros
and bass that were defined as and i was
like at some point i was like oh i
really want to learn julia i want to
impress like my david sanders my high
school my gran
my course professor and i was like i'm
going to learn all the julia macros and
i was like oh how do i do how do i do it
and then i stumbled on to auto
completion and i was like oh they're all
defined in different places but they all
start with the add signs so i just i
just have to start with base dot at and
then type tab tab and then those are all
the macros define and base
right that's it
well all the ones that are yeah yeah
i think counts all the exported ones
so i could be like what is pure
right
and pure the doctrine is wrong it should
say don't use pure you are not james
nash
but um
yeah it just doesn't work as what people
from functional languages think it works
in julia
so yeah
all right let's keep going
this is the worst possible
julia code ever
break or continue oh
i need to fix that
uh
return
zero
yeah return maxwell let's do that
so this is the worst possible geocode
you could write to calculate this
and so we're gonna go through some
editing
[Music]
dojos to try and figure out effective
editing techniques
so
let's say that i'm at the beginning of
this function
if i now type in
control space
and i'm at the end of this function and
i'm typing control space
instead of having to go all the way back
up
there's this shortcut called control x
so you jump in between different parts
of the
function
with control x so
this isn't normally useful for me
because i don't write like
150 line
rebel functions usually like they don't
spend multiple screens but if they did
jumping around with this
um you it's called setting a mark so you
set a mark and then you
are able to
oh my god
you're able to
jump between them i just realized
another typo there
read me
counter
all right
we'll get that when we're done
all right so next drill i think this is
probably the most informative exercise
you could do if you really want to
practice a lot of these key key
combinations
um
so this is the most horrible
unformatted julie code you could ever
write
and i try to write
i try to
write a couple of comments that could
help you
in
clearing up a lot of the
stuff that was wrong with this function
before i get into that i'm going to look
at questions from the chat yes elias
spotted that mine
how do you
wait um
i know that about python real funny is
the clipboard things smart in linux
different ds implement different
clipboards i don't know if it's smart
but it works with at least the last
thing
um my ripple doesn't show emojis oof you
might be on windows and you might need
other fonts
um shimoda's hideous and windows is
there a way to make it useful
i don't know off hand what i do is turn
into a good patch but that doesn't work
faster than the health research and docs
for the word counter goes yeah elias
noticed something horrible by my code
i use telly cell too no possible works
not possible otherwise i will use it all
right sorry yeah can't fix your work
environment for now
um
but if you're at home and you have the
spare time to try and
get a bit more fluent with a bit of
these commands we're going to do the
following exercise all together
so
we're going to go to the beginning
right
then we're gonna go to the next line
um then ctrl
delete delete
uh
all right
so now we're gonna go to the
uh oops line and if we press control k
we're going to kill the rest of the line
um we're going to go here
we're going to go control word to scroll
back
here
alt f to go forward
um
yeah i can draw w to go backwards again
uh ctrl w to delete backwards again
we're to get this
control n to go to the beginning next
line then control a
to go to the beginning of this line then
control k to kill it
ctrl k k
go backwards kill that with control w
ctrl
n and forward forward ctrl w oh sorry
that wasn't supposed to be that one
so this one there's this other thing
that's um meta l
oh no
so if you're
um
if you're if you want to
change the from uppercase to lowercase
you can just type in metal
and so that will lower case the entire
word if you're at the beginning of it
um you'll notice that there's some weird
thing with how the rebel
keeps displaying colors i don't know why
that happens
um
but it is no i've known that that
happens for a while
so instead of break this has to be
return
minus one and now another really
interesting one is the that you can do
uh meta up
because this
this um this line should be at the
beginning so you can do alt up
to scroll back up to the top
and then you can do
uh forward ctrl w
and ctrl w nope all w
and so this is wrongly indented instead
of do you can do alt
left
[Music]
so
that
is still wrong
hmm all right because i did um
that
there we go
so this is how it ends up
this is what it looked
like and um
yeah just
two little playing grounds so people can
see a few examples and get a bit more
comfortable with that
i'm gonna look at
what people are saying though
um
nothing there
oh i think my banner is done oh no i'm
just gonna leave it there
why
not um
yeah so the problem for that is that a
very dedicated cat ran across the
keyboard maliciously writing oops all
over the place
and
that should be called um
then read me
the cat
oh i forgot to
return
[Music]
-1
so i could do
n-r-u-t-e-r
uh
yeah
and that's the last thing that i want to
show people there's this cool
um if you want to switch the
to
ah
break
yeah if you want to change these two
[Music]
characters about the cursor you can type
in ctrl k
and so that will
flip them
with ctrl t for transpose right
awesome
um
what else is new
there's a
control undo for the previous action
control k will kill to the end of the
line and they'll add it to your kill
ring we'll talk about that later
control d will delete one character and
advance the word control
w will go backwards and delete the word
you can lowercase entire word you can
also uppercase a word it's in the manual
um meta up i found really useful to
float
uh middle left to
reindent right um
so all of this talk about bindings means
that you can also define your own
bindings and so this means the
looking at a little bit too much
internals for my liking for this
workshop
but
um regardless
you can still do that right
you need to do it via the line edit api
so you're gonna do line edit mode
history history previous or edit move up
so
i
this is now
vim keys with control k and ctrl j
instead of control n and control p
and so you set up the reple interface
there
if you're really interested you can go
and read the source code it's not the
most friendly julia code
and this is known it's one of the parts
of julia that has been quite untouched
and
a little bit unmaintained for the
better part of julie's existence
if you ask stefan karpinsky about it
he'll be like yep it's we we would do
things differently now but it's what we
have
um
i won't be talking about um deep julian
turner's
uh julia repple internals
because
that would be just
not a spectacle for many people
all right i think i'm going to take a
little bit of a break
after i answer some questions
um
does anyone have to remove the tab
change focus feature in vs code or tried
various rebel commands i thought we
could make congestions in the code in
rebel i just wanted i just wanted that
the devs went with the bim approach the
section has already started giving me
rsi yes and that's why i don't use the
emacs bindings and so part of this
presentation has been about
inviting everyone into i want vim key
bindings can someone please be nerd
sniped into
contributing that into julia or at least
having a decent package um
i think
arbit random user has suggested a bit
um
has already posted two different repos
about people who started that but it
definitely needs a lot more support
all right
i'm going to
have a little bit of a break
see y'all in in live three minutes
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're back peeps
i didn't find screen keys for max wood
possibly doesn't exist it might not
um
there's probably an equivalent program
for showing um there's definitely an
accessibility feature in mac for showing
that
all right
so we're done with julian mode for now
um
we're gonna go through a
wait did i show
uh
reverse
oh i didn't show this that's my bad
um last thing before we move out
from julian mode if you're using oh my
rebel
it's going to be a bit different but if
you do this ctrl r
you're gonna start doing
fuzzy search over your inputs right so
if i type in
horrible
it will start autocompleting with a
fuzzy search which is like a more
approximate search like closer to like a
search engine i think
um about the
previous inputs that you've uh sent to
the repo
and so you can do stuff like so remember
control r to search in reverse and you
can type in x
and so
it will show me all the things that
started with x and then all things that
then contained x
um
so you can do that quite
um
you this can be quite effective
for searching for stuff so i can do
function
ham
[Music]
g
right and then it pulls that up
so you can see you can have a little bit
of more of an interactive search
and what's really cool is that you can
do
let's say
um
using and then
like that
that's the last one
that
i recall typing in and then you can do
control f
wait that didn't work
you can do ctrl f
ctrl f
x control f
all right so there's a there's a way
that you can go with like backwards
fuzzy search and forwards fuzzy search
with control f i think
um but
uh reverse mode is what i use 99 of the
time
um
all right
so that's it for um the julian mode
we're going to talk now about other
rebel modes so we're gonna go and talk
about the help mode i've used it a
little bit
but you to get into the help mode
you type in the question mark
and then uh by the way you also get
autocomplete here
right so if you don't remember what the
parse function did
then you can
or what the parse function was called
it will auto complete so this will throw
a bunch of dock strings right wow
but if you type in something that's a
little bit more
there we go terse then we can get the
clipboard function to
hopefully show us a few examples about
uh what it does what types it expects
um
in a few examples right um
so for example well for example i'm
saying a lot of examples um
what's another function that i really
like
um
fine first
is a function that not a lot of people
know
and so i will type that in
and then i can
oh no
i've been
uh i think
i
think i need to do something like
uh set
scroll
on
oh all right so this is something with
my
freaking t-mux config this is a new
config that i screwed up but the point
is if you type in
let's say
um
let's try the any function oh no that
was a lot
uh you you get a lot of different let's
try
any or
um
yeah let's try that
um you can get the title like this is a
little bit more formatted than this text
you can get um special characters like
represented by the rebel like these are
blue
right
when it's code
you can also have um note warnings
for the different julie versions
so what i recommend that people try out
to actually get hang of everything that
everything that's being displayed is a
rendered markdown dock string right so
you can write this in markdown
and how you write it is you just include
a string just above your function
um that's one way to do it so now if i
ever ask
julia hey what's hamming i'll say oh
super helpful string comment
and i'm like um that wasn't very useful
you can also add doc strings this way
and you can go like
way more useful way more pretty
let's do dancer
yeah way more pretty
and then
hamming right
so if i ever now ask
hamming
i have one entry that was the
um
that was the original doc string
final
let's say
final dock right
and so you can keep
adding um
duck strings
um
no it's ta-da
there we go
so i can ask hey what's this hamming
thing
and
there was the one that i included like
in the function definition and then this
one will overtake that um
what's interesting is that um
so hamming
methods you can ask for the methods that
the hamming function defined
right
and so you're like all right i can ask
about that but if you ever
do something like
hey hamming is just defined for x
int
and let's say that this square is
the input
and then you want to add in a doctrine
for
square
right square
block
i don't remember
um square
cross
all right let's leave it at that
oh my bad
oh hamming
and then three
right this will
include so this is a very julian version
of doc strings because
as you bring in as you add more
dispatches to a
method call you'll get different um
you'll get more dog strings right so
let's say that
the i'm looking at the dot strings for
um
this
right
uh for the squaring number or
which one do i have yeah which one do i
want yeah that one um if i ever do using
sparse rays
and sparse arrays happens to define
stuff on
that okay no sparse raise is a really
bad example for that but if you and if
you bring in new modules or namespaces
and they have additional documents on
top of the methods those will get added
afterwards so
that's something really cool
um oh what are we going to find here
elbow cough
all right
um should be ctrl s for forward search
oh thanks peter
so what i really recommend is that
people try adding because it's markdown
there's a couple of different um
hamingo oh my god
not the jamingo
mingo
right
um because it's markdown um i definitely
recommend that people check out what is
possible in the par stocks
and you can do that with the at edit
parse
int
one two three and so
if you scroll up
to almost the beginning of the file you
can see that there's
a lot of different
stuff that you can write so there's this
combat thing
there's examples you can include a
region of dock tests these get run
when you're using documenter
um
so
there's quite a few you can you can also
add let me show people
um
oh i'm there
um
i was doing the hamming right so let's
go to
[Music]
super
super whoop
so i'm going to try the reverse search
so it's super useful there we go
um control a to go to the beginning
um
alt f
oh no all backwards
super useful string comment
and then
yeah i think i want the triple quotes
you don't need triple quotes but i just
find them helpful
so let's do a few of these
right now
examples
and then
one two three four
and then
uh what was that thing
jail
dog test
and so you do
julia
[Music]
i mean
a b
a c
and so that should be
oh no
uh one
right
so if i ever ask julia what is the
hamming doc string
right oh the examples already has a
banner for it right
i don't need the additional
gel
hemming so you can get really pretty
printing uh you can get tons of pretty
printing there here
um with the jewelry code formatting that
you're already seeing in the rebel so
that's very nice
um
just one last thing that i want to show
you
super helpful comment
and then
so
you can do this is
you can do a string
and then a string
and then this will be an end
right
so if i do
that
this gets nicely formatted
i can show some examples
all the good stuff
all right so yeah don't be afraid to
look at um
cool stuff you can do oh final thing
that not a lot of people know
um
you can
do
this
extended help
and you can type in
super secret super
verbose explanation of the hamming
distance
useful for
genomics
counts how many
base pairs
differ
right
and so what's really cool is that if you
just do um
if you just get the doctrine for parse
it doesn't show up but there's this nice
command that says oh there's extended
help available
so if you type in double question mark
and then you do hamming
then it comes out
counts right super verbose is
useful for genomics right so you can
have people opt in to documentation
um by adding in way more stuff and
putting it under the extended help
also
uh leaner um
let's see
if you just type in the name of a module
and they don't have an associated docs
string i think this is the case for
data frames i think i remember data
frames using this
i think it's from julia 1.8
on
might be
um if you don't have the
if you don't have a doc string for your
main module it will just pull in the
readme so data frames
yeah it'll just pull in the the entire
readme oh no
so i can't scroll up right now but
you know you get the point like this is
all the readme and this will just
generate default documentation for your
main module which is pretty cool
um
i should add that um
vim read
me
all
extended
if you don't have a box string
your
main
module
for your main module
just display
your
repose
readme
cool stuff
um
all right
things that people didn't know about
their jewelry rebel help mode extend
help um all right yeah propose uh
there's this function i didn't find too
useful
um at the beginning it's called i
propose
i think it's from it comes from like
linux
times so you can ask
like hey what are all the
julia functions that contain the args
keyword like any
mention of args
within their doc strings and so this
will say oh yeah all these contain it
i think it's um
yeah so it also exists in um
unix this tilde utility is amazing
um search for a keyword using a regular
expression search without restricting
the output to a terminal keyword right
search the manual pages for names and
descriptions yeah so this just searches
all the unix span packages for whatever
regular expression you passed in and you
don't even need to type in the function
name because you just type in like let's
say
args
and that will give you the same
information so i could just be like hey
what was that um dancer thing
um sorry
that was the answer in the help strings
and okay i didn't have dancer but if i
have
what was the example i tried
um yeah let's try unicode
unicode
then all of these functions have
something that that says unicode within
their doc strings right
[Music]
furthermore if you happen to know
regular expressions you can use those in
your
so a regular expression in julia is
defined like this
right
that's
you can ask
hey what's that thing and we'll say oh
actually
um r equals that and then you're like
what's this r thing and there's like oh
that's a regex retics whatever it's
called and but you can do stuff like oh
this is
these are all the things that contain
that
or you can do arg let's i want to know
all the things that define some numbered
argumentation all right yeah art tools
does that and for some reason invoking
atomic
funny that
um
so if you ever need regular expressions
for part searching for all your dog
strengths they're there
things that people don't
maybe know sometimes is that you can
also
just type in a character oh okay i
missed that
um you can just type it in
i would count this as sort of a rebel
mode help
um
we'll see why in a second but and so you
get like the entire unicode
representation
it says the category it's in it's a
letter it's lowercase
um
[Music]
that that's wrong
then readme
so
right
cool
um what is cool is that you can just
type in um
characters wait was that what i wanted
to write no
um but i definitely can
oh my god
if you just type in
like the partials unicode function uh
unicode character
julia will very helpfully
let you know how you can write that
with like auto completion thingy from
within
julia right so if i don't know how to
type in
dancer
like this emoji
it'll say hey you can type dancer by
dancer and then tapping
so yeah
that's useful i think
um
[Music]
i like this shell mode hack someone has
a channel hack
yeah tilder is amazing um
extend help
right uh we're almost done with hulk
mode
so yeah that was a reverse latex slash
emoji lookup that was very useful
and um
shell mode
is the last remaining canonical julia
mode so if you type in
um
semicolon no
semicolon
you run into this thing called show mode
so shell mode is an emulation not
emulation but like it's a fake shell in
the sense that it's just
julia code parsing what you want to do
and then letting you try and do it
so
i can do ls so if you're in unix ls will
show you they'll it will list your
directory i can do um bat which is a
nice pager for the
let's say the license
right so it will
pretty print that
um
this show mode doesn't let you do stuff
like oh by the way um normally you can
do like word count on the
license file
ah all right ctrl c to get rid of that
so you could do word count on license
remember i can tab complete
so i just did
word count lie and then autocomplete
um
but you can't run that on
like you can't do ls
and pipe that into
word count
right
uh i think this is supposed to be xrx
it doesn't matter um it's because um
you don't get access to piping in this
shell mode
you do however
get access to julia
so
you could do redeer
call that
so
and then this will execute
hello
i'm sorry so you could do stuff like
read deer
there you go
so
you can
do simple shell scripting from within
your shell
um
and interpolate that so i think
oh no okay that's not uh
so x is not bound in my normal shell and
it tried to look for that or it tried to
do something with the rust stuff that's
installed
but
if i do
x
like echo
x
that's because
x here is defined there right so you can
do all of a bunch of julia code right
funky julia code
and then get back you know
files equals
please
dot
please no
text
and and then you can do
all right yeah touch
and then
files
and then
that works
right
so that can also work
um
yeah that's the that's the gem shown
here
um
so
what i find
most useful about the julie rebel
show mode is
being able to have like a very fast um
text tabs there that i can open up make
a quick file change
and then jump back into the rebel so
it's not uncommon so i've done it a few
times during this video but i'm going to
talk you through it now
so let's find the typo that i've made
here
this extended help this now can now be
deleted
so what i do is i just
type semicolon
vim readme get the autocomplete right
and then i do slash to search
extended
i type in n to go to the next one and i
just
do
dot cc that deletes it
uh
and then i save and quit
and now i can get
added on git
commit
am and then fix more typos
right get push origin
and then i do control l and it buffers
that so
all in all it's like it once you get
into the habit of doing that
and now
i can
i've deleted it
yeah
excellent
um
i think i'm going to take a few
questions and a strategic sip of water
before i go into the package mode
all right
um what are we gonna find what os is
miguel using grant i'm using pop os
i it just seemed like the most the
easiest way to
um
get set up with a
debian but it's basically ubuntu with
like more
productivity defaults
um yeah pop os
but it's basically an ubuntu
all right
any questions before we move on to
package mode
now this is probably the
i don't know if it's the biggest
productivity boost you can get with
julia it's probably this in revise
so
any questions before i move on to
package mode
questions questions questions
grant says thank you don't see anything
of the discord
awesome
all right this is the real productivity
booster if there is one thing you take
away from today or if you want to just
get people hyped on the rebel
make it the
knowing how to manage stuff from the
package mode
rebel
so this is what we're going to do
[Music]
other languages have
ways that you can install packages into
the language
um
sometimes they just leave it up to you
like c plus plus
like there's some package managers but
they're not bolted into the language
like julia and rust says
and so what's really cool about julie is
you don't need to leave your coding
environment for their code
to
be installed have it reloaded and try
and rerun the code you can just do that
dynamically
so
now
in the newest julia you can do using
let's say what's the package that i
haven't used in a while
unicode plots
maybe i don't know if i have it on this
machine but the point is if you don't
have it
julia will now try it will prompt you
hey so for example i'm gonna remove
unicode
plots
right
and so that's something that you can do
um so first of all you enter the package
mode rebel with
a square bracket let's wait for the
there we go
let's wait a bit four seconds
and so if i'm just normal jeweler mode i
type in right square bracket
and that will instantly put me into the
package mode rebel
and so i can now do add
unicode
plots right i don't want to do that
right now because i want to show off
that
it's equivalent to doing this
right and i'll say oh it wasn't found
but there's a package that matches that
so you can just type in yes
enter
or y enter and it'll go and do that and
so now
i can just do
scatter plot
and
then
i have
um
plots in my terminal
right
um something that so once again
you
just keep trying to autocomplete
everywhere if i just type in add diff
and then tab
it will show me everything in the
recalculus verse
right like
difficulty tutorials uncertainty
differential backward differentiable
metabolism difficulty flux difficult gpu
difficulty based stand all the
registered tvq stuff
is available for auto condition uh
likewise you could do
intern
interactive
in turn
strings
interpolation
[Music]
everything
it's there it has to be a registered
julia package
other things that people might not know
um when you're developing a julia
package
um so for example i don't have any tests
here that's we can
so i'm gonna write tests and it's gonna
dump all the things that i have
um
but and so this is a
chart of like hey you have this
installed at this version you have this
is the git commit to get that all that
stuff
um i don't have anything there let's put
a few tests
so vim
tests
run tests and so i'll do
hey
um test two equals two
awesome
right
so now
i can just type in test
and it will
very nicely say
oh you just did a pass total
here's a really cool thing that you were
probably not expecting it might be a
little bit of a context switch but this
will be
shown during the conference but i want
to cover it right now there's an amazing
tool we're going to exit julia
this amazing tool called julia up
right and it lets you do all of these
different things
so
what with julia up what you can do is
manage all of your different julia
installed versions
so i can do julia list oh sorry julia
list
oh no
julia up help
julia up
um
status
right that's the one
by the way if you ever want your most
recently typed in shell command oh no it
doesn't work in fish
um
so with julia up i have installed julia
1.7 july 1.8 release and source right
um
i don't know why i have 1.7.3 and
release as well but all right that's not
the point the point is that i can do
julia up
default 1.0
and then go
change to that julia version and then
start julia
with that new version and so this all
happens automatically in the background
and so
in this in the newest julia version this
is what i wanted to show if i run test
i think it's due to a pr by ian weaver
you will now get
the time that your tests take
so this is a very useful way to check
out like really quick fixes or like
incompatibilities between your julie
versions you just need to
you know exit the julie version and then
julia up default and then 1.7.3
and then julia minus project and then
i'm there
we're going to talk a little bit more
about flags in a bit
but yeah
um so if i type in test now you can see
that i'm in julia 1.7.3
and it's gonna run very quickly
and there's no timing anymore so this is
the way that you if you're trying to
upgrade your packages or you're trying
to maintain different uh a package for
different julie versions this is the
best sanctioned way that you should
definitely manage your julia
installations themselves managing your
julia packages in your julia code do
that through the package manager julia
versions themselves do it through do it
up david anthony's going to cover it
it's an amazing tool i really appreciate
it it's built in rust all power to them
but the point is
that's how you use test
and if you didn't know
you can also test for different packages
so let's see
let's test
um progress meter or latexify
um
that's fine let's try testing the dexify
so you can run the test for a particular
package it doesn't only have to be the
one in your and the one that you've
activated the environment on so it's i
don't know running uh macro tests or
something i don't really care um but the
point is it can be done
um
all right
so
you can ask for a status to get a dump
of everything that's installed but you
can also do st there's a couple of
shortcuts
in the package reple
so just st stands for status
um also if you're ever trying to
um
if you're ever trying to
and
make a small sandbox of an
environment you can do this activate
minus minus temp
and so that will be a throwaway
environment and if you try to do all of
your installations there
then it won't affect any other
environment so when you're done with it
it'll just be deleted
that's really useful when you're just
trying to
work a minimum you're making a minimum
working example i recently did uh found
this very useful when i was trying to
find a bug that affects my computer
because of some mackie installation
stuff not linking the proper clang
library or symbols defined somewhere so
the easiest way to know that i wasn't
working my setup was to just say what is
a clean environment that i can just jump
into right now and you can do that with
activate minus minus 10. so activate
what it does is
you do you can tell it
um to
have
right to be in a certain environment
or
wait activate
activate there we go
right
so i'm
here
and
now all of the installations that i do
happen
in this environment but if i ever
leave the environment
with just a normal activate and i ask
hey what are the things that are
installed you can see that abstract
trees is installed for the rebel mastery
workshop thing but it isn't installed
for my global workshop or for my global
environment my global environment only
has like these other things
but the rebel mastery doesn't have that
actually i should
remove a few of those but that's not the
point
um so
you're using one key part of the puzzle
to be extremely productive in julia
and that is instantiate so instantiate
will eagerly
download all the dependencies of an
environment so if you ever want to know
if your co-workers code really works on
your computer you can just use
their package you go into the map you go
into the directory right
let's say that you're
right you're here
you go home right then you're like all
right let's do this julia
dev thing
and then you go into the rebel
mastery workshop
and you're like oh what is this thing
and then you can just type in
instantiate
and so that instantiate what will it do
is it will download all the code
that is defined in the environment and
it will
and so you'll know if you can install
all of those things so instantly you can
know that you can pull in all the
dependencies that your collaborators
defined in their project
so they have to be like conscious that
they're adding things to the environment
and work in a certain way but once you
do that once you get into the habit of
always activating an environment
it's so much easier
as a really quick tip for making that
easier um you might have noticed that i
did this but if you do
julia minus minus project it will auto
magically start julia with the
appropriate
environment right
so that's something very useful in fact
i almost always alias
um jp as julia project so i'll just jump
into a repo i'll just jump into a folder
and then jp and then i already have the
environment set up it's
probably better to set it up that way
if you're
once you get the mental model and or at
least having a shortcut for it
all right
questions
uh
rainer
raina is trying to find out how to do
multiple letter subscripts
um
that together with unicode plots is a
big show off we're gonna get to we're
gonna we're gonna do a lot more in the
last hour just to wait um
people are helping you with you know
rebel completions
uh yeah unicode it doesn't
uh allow you
to subscript all the letters it's
enraging um
we've screened we've tried screaming at
them it hasn't helped
lastly if you've been using julia for a
while
um
for across different versions so like
since 1.0 or before that and you've
never run
gc try that
it might free up a few gigabytes
um
it means garbage collect
the packages that julian knows you won't
be using ever
um
yeah
so
hello all right
um
there's revise and that's the big thing
that i want to talk about
um
because there's definitely a before and
after once you get to using revise and
we're going to show off how to
specifically do it
installation
right so first of all you advervise
um
activate
so this will add revised
other key features of revised
um
hello
configuration there we go
so you put in this
little script from the revised
documentation
and so
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to go to this
file if you don't have this file
you just
build it
so it's julia config
start up
and then you
yeah this is the proper way to set it up
once you have that what you're supposed
to do is the following
um
let's say that we have a file called um
revise me
right so this function will say
hello
and then says
julie khan 22
says hi to
that person
right and also what do i want i want um
temp equals 909
so once you're using
revise
then you can do include t notice the t
you can do revise me and so what will
this basically sets up like a watching
system
where it keeps you updated on any
changes that happen to the file
so
what you can do is i was like oh what
was that hello function um
i think that was hello elias who's in
the chat and so chilicon 202 says hi to
elias and so i say all right i want to
go back and edit that
so i do that oh my god it's still set up
to that thing
it's still set up to nano
and i was like no no it's maybe it's not
julicon uh that but it's maybe
maybe it's just chat
um
write out
nope
it's right out and
uh enter and then exit
all right end
editor enter yeah let's never do that
again
um
and so if i run hello elias again
now
that function is redefined in my rebel
environment
right so let's demo that again edit
hello
um
edit ctrl p to go back ctrl p to go back
up again and so i'll be like oh chat
says
that and i'm like
what's up
i'll just control uh i save and quit and
then i do
hello
elias
and it's what's up elias right so i only
have to worry about like trying to run
my code and so you can have this tracing
through your packages
right and just be editing a file at a
time you can just be playing around the
rebel and when you figure out what's
what's working you can just do add edit
jump straight into the function change
what needs to be changed and then you
know
activate
like let's say that oh this this is a
good demo too um
uh vim
source and then
julia
uh
auto complete that
and i'll be like all right um
export
so hello
is x and it should be equal to
that
export the hello
and i'll be like all right using ripple
mastery right it's pre-compiling
it did some really fast pre-compilation
um so i'm like all right so i can do
hello with
um uh let's say hi to
grant who's also in chat what's up grant
um
so then i realized that i'm like all
right i wanna run all these tests
and my tests passed but i'm like oof i
didn't have any tests
that really checked that i was
definitely saying hi to grant so
if i say hello to a grant
this should definitely be equal to
the sub grant
i'll exit that
and so i'll be like all right test that
oh it didn't work because it now
it outputs grant graham right
and so i can be like okay that's wrong
let's edit
that
and it should be
wait
shouldn't it
hello grant what's up grant
yeah
uh oh maybe it's because
ah
it's saying grant grant
uh it's under the last one
hmm
[Music]
all right
somebody's gonna correct me in like a
few seconds telling me i'm doing
something really dumb
and i'm gonna
give myself yep that's thing so this is
why i want to
um this is what i wanted to check with
the
subgram
what's up
right this is what i want to check that
i'm
so now before i run the test i could be
like wait does it even work and so i
could be like hello
cramp
and i see that it works and i'm like all
right let me just run the tests so i run
a mini example and then i can go back to
running the tests right so that's the
sort of workflow that revised enables
you to have is that you can just jump in
and out of functions run something
really quick on the ripple and then go
back to running your tests so that you
know that things are happening
appropriately you can also have like a
split
view of this but that's like the the big
big big productivity booster that
revised has um
what is all this
there we go
can you improve rebel perf by lowering
compiler optimization level say from o3
to o1 yes you can get
you can start julia with optimize like
minus minus optimized equals one if you
want uh grant says what's up back
awesome
um yeah so someone's saying that there's
a couple flags
so if you ever want to know you can
start julia with you can just feed julia
minus minus help and there's all of
these different flags
for
um stuff that you can do with julia and
specifically there's the mint up level
zero one two three said lower bound on
topisation level or minus minus
optimized that's the one that i said
right you can also change the threads
the thread count if there's a banner
history all that stuff
so yeah
uh that can be done um
all right um i've i've demoed a bit of
revised i just want to give a shout out
to this uh rebel maker package
uh by mason prodder
and so
you can
very quickly make
different rebel modes so we've seen four
right uh you can make your own
you can make an expression mode
where
you can just
be shown the coded version of your of
your code
you can interpolate you can make lisp
mode
right
by just
feeding the macro straight from your
apple mode into
the lisp
um into your lispy interpreter so you
can have lists within julia right
um
and so this package is amazing and you
should definitely check it out there's
definitely a lot of things that can
be facilitated with this package
um creating a rebel mode at start time
right there we go
packages using rebel maker oh there's a
small ipl implementation oh my god it
now uses rebel maker
oof
awesome
okay i'm i just got nerd sniped a little
bit but yeah rebel maker is amazing
uh cross language uh comparison of rebel
features i might do that later but i'm
just building a huge i'm trying to be
more quantitative about
and qualitative about specifically what
things that julie ripple offers that
other languages don't offer but it's
just a big time investment so julia has
a package manager a shell mode um
there's julian mode
you can also do benchmarking you can
also
um
you can't delete functions you can't
delete variables those are all things
that define like how the julie rebel can
behave but julia's not the first
language to come up with rebels so what
exists out there and so i found some
really cool things like in lisp you can
re-complete you can recompile your
entire language um with a single like
emacs command and that's pretty cool
like you can just hack on the language
itself and then have it all recompile
then you can have it's called um
break loop debugging so you can have
the
you can type in an entire function right
like let's say that i have the i don't
need you anymore i let's say that i did
uh function
um
break loop
right and so i defined
if let's say g of x so
if g of x
is interesting then
return
three
and and then h of x right so there's a
lisby way in which you can define this
function and then call break loop
uh four
and then this error gets not this
this the rebel right now just says all
right this wasn't defined but in enlist
this will now prompt you for hey define
g now
so it's a very lispy way of building up
programs with just like naming things
and then worrying about it later
and it's really powerful
uh we don't have that sort of
programming
style in julia yet but this is a project
um that i'm willing to suggest to people
please
so i'm gonna add that to the list of
projects at the end of this repo
projects
implement
break loop
coding style
whenever
a function
is not defined
prompt
the user to
define it
and then keep on evaluating
so
this is function break loop
if g of
let's do that
if g of x
return 3
and
h of x
so
break loop
one
when
break loop
one
runs
prompt the user
to define g of x
and then
resume
running
break loop
of one
yeah
okay
terminus and font support i was going to
talk about that but it's um
it's very tough
um startup file options
um
yeah let's talk about that
so there's this file that i have
um
config
nope that's in julia uh actually
uh before i get into that let me talk
about um
let's look at some questions
all right no questions
all right last hour um
let me show you some startup file
options um
so these are the things that i've always
defined i always want on my reply i
always want benchmark tools and i always
want the fix and i always want revise
there's these other functions that you
haven't you don't know what they do yet
and i'm going to talk about them in a
bit
so
first i'm going to talk about uh
surprise surprise oh my god that's a
horrible typo
um
so this can say
julie kong 2022
and now
i've changed my prompt
so this one's just saying
right
so i don't know if people knew that they
could do that but i found it really
amusing
um
so let's try it again surprise
horrible
um
snow so hanky
okay but i need the character thingy
there we go
can i convert an object of type
oh my god
stop whining julia so
there we go
this is oh wait i want to do
there we go now we know it's legit
super
super useful rebel mode
right don't ever do this um do it for
like five seconds just to show your
friends that you can do it but then this
breaks
your
other people's ability to copy paste
your code
so surprise i think i just yeah there we
go um
people can
so if i do
i think i've shown it um but if not no
worries
uh where is it
where is it
all right yeah so people can do this
um you can copy and then paste it and
then the julia
glitter then
gets
cut out
so that's very useful when you're just
copying paste code from stack overflow
or from slack or from people trying to
help you
don't change your prompt i know it can
be done but
it's a bad thing
i just showed it off because i think
it's funny right now but yeah um
yes peter chen julia up works very well
for me on linux i would definitely try
it on linux especially on linux actually
um
yeah that's a little easter egg that i
wanted to show people not everyone knows
that you can do that
um
also you do
little a few flags that people might not
know about um that i
that i i find useful there's the julia
quiet flag
oh my god
um let's install the fix
and while i look at some questions
oh sorry
um
so
let's try that again
uh julia my spine is
we'll just start julia without the
banner
um
so you don't get the super funky
greeting
then there's julia minus minus project
and that will start your julia with uh
in the actual environment that you want
to work at
your you can actually feed the minus
minus project
uh flag a path
um there's a lot more there's one that i
don't think that a lot of people have
run into so i'm gonna
talk about it now
which is this one
um
so because julia is built on llvm
there's a
flag that you can pass to julia
um
called lvm julia args and it's called
minus time passes so this will
pick up on wait let me
um
let's do unicode plots
so this will try and time all the
this will measure all the time that
julius spent optimizing code in the llvm
passes so
all right all right
um
i think this is because i changed my
default
yeah
so
that one
julia
[Music]
that's the one
can you store julius server locally and
bind several clients to the same back
end yes you can sharing or attaching to
a julia session among several processes
yes that's distributed computing
not going to talk about it here except
for the fact that it exists and other
people will be talking about it at the
conference um
i wanted to show off this flag
lvm
underscore args
and then
using
the
unicode
plots
revised
uh let's see what people are asking
i can see that one can edit one's codes
inside the ripple using revised thank
you my question is what is a surf way to
save all the code one has entered into
the ripple i made a package that has a
functionality for that and i'm going to
talk about it in a sec
um
there's a bare-bones way
and there's a not so bad bonus way um
[Music]
and i'm just going to talk about this
uh
scatter plot one here
one there
please work
scatter plot
okay finally
hopefully
jeebus
so this will run that entire part
hello
all right so i need to
look more carefully into what that did
because
apparently it doesn't print it out like
i thought it would
all right well i'm gonna have to look
that up
um
all right i showed you how to change a
prompt
um also you can activate you can name
your environments
so or i think
by orgs
um
let's try to change the banner
so
julia
banner
uh
i will now
banner
banner try and find it
where is it
give me my banner
all right
so this is the part where i just go
uh
that's
julia
cd
depth
oh wait
cd julia and then i'm like all right
just show me where the banner is defined
so
there's this very useful
okay
julia julia
j julia
j oss
julia
right um
banner there we go
oh my god
fd
function banner io there we go base
version
so if i do
vim
bass version
jl
banner
right
so this is the entire julie banner
and if you don't like that banner
what you can do is you can just
overwrite that
so we're going to do that now
and we're gonna do it via
we did it with
edit uh let's see where do i where did i
find stuff here
edit
parse there oof that's horrible again
but it's in
okay i remember where it is now
so
vim
julia up
um
ben
julia
julia
bin
julia
[Music]
launcher
never mind
so if i do just the
bare bones julia
um
[Music]
less
uh
which
parse
and one to three
yes
there
but doesn't show me
and
there you go edit
parse
this is in
wow
i
didn't know how to
read that that was way too tiny and fun
probably this one looks very promising
remote ripple yeah people are asking
questions all right um i was trying to i
was going to try to um change my banner
but i
don't know why i'm not able to
julia
um julia pop
there we go
i'm on the
okay
i don't need that right
bim
there we go
for the moment of truth
uh
let's make sure to
comment this entire thing
and then
sorry people aren't able to see that
there we go it should be good now
else
print io
and now
the doggy
so
that should have worked
and so if i pull up julia
i'm definitely using that version yes i
am
please okay i don't know i didn't
um i might have to recompile
but
oh well
um
yeah the point is that that can be done
i'll get it next time
all right more showing off cool uh repos
that people have built
um
there's a
there's a nice easter egg that people
might not know about and that's uh you
can start julia with minus minus
femtolisp
julia mines manufamto
julia mine's minus femto
julia manchman's lisp
there we go femtolisp so if you happen
to know the julia lore
jeff had written a lisp somewhere during
his time when he was studying
and it's just
uh
it was a really quick way for them to
have a parser for julia at the very
beginning i don't remember how to do
this uh def
um
name
and then x
and then three
i don't remember how to do
um
uh lisp here but the point is
exit
exit
there we go
uh yeah you can tap into the parser that
way and there's actually
let me see if i can recall
there's a way that you can
jail in it
i think
there's a
there's a certain symbol you can call
to start the julia process but i don't
remember right now
um
how do i even see there's no rebel here
so i feel like a duck out of water oh
well that was weird all right
um banner um tools and packages
so now i'm just gonna try and breeze
through as many cool packages as i can
um changing the banner alan turing would
be proud of the development in the field
lolo yeah
um people saying kick w
maybe that's what you're in the prom i
think the ripple breaks because there's
a variable jail prop link that happened
somewhere inside the ripple startup yeah
i'm gonna make a nice little silly blog
post of things you should definitely
shouldn't do with the ripple or
something
well it's just silly
it's just for showing off
um tools and packages
all right um
no more questions so far let's let's
look at some really cool stuff that
julie has out of the box
um
you can ask uh julia to tell you when
you're definitely screwing up
so if you're doing
it will run the code in front of you or
in front of the macro and i'll say with
some pretty color output hey
don't do that
or when you definitely
shouldn't have so if you happen to
pollute type inference like if you
happen to have screwed up
or not have helped julie out as much as
you could have it will print it out in
red
and there's a bunch of these the point
is that there's a bunch of um
of these macros of like hey how does
um x equals two
um
code lower oh that's why
there's a
there's a lot of transformation passes
that have to happen
from you running julico to julia
actually running the code
and so knowing all these different
code
uh friends is very useful for
being able to inspect
what's going on underneath the hood at
many different levels
right
so absolutely
definitely auto complete them play
around with them figure out what's fun
um uh just for all the haters out there
who say that julia can never be fast
you know that's you can have the code
typed and then you can have the
code native so you can have
there's your assembly
if you're really into into that
um
benchmark tools um benchmark tools is
probably the
number one leading
cause of performance junkies in julia
that's not benchmark tools
that is benchmark tools so what
benchmark will do
is it will let's say that i want to
square this
really big number
or
let's say a big
that's not a number
um
and squares should definitely be defined
there we go
ctrl p control p
and so what this will do is it will
evaluate the thing in front of the at
benchmark a bunch of times and get some
samples on how quickly it happened it
will print a nice graphic in your
terminal and it'll say you know
it you allocated 48 bytes
you did three allocations if you if
you're getting into performance that's
very important to know about and on
average you were
or this is the range when
your best time was 66 nanoseconds the
worst time was 171 microseconds
um so from when you didn't hit the
garbage collector to win you did
sorry
um if you're if you don't want that
verbose of a printout you can just do at
b time and then that will be
enough to show you oh
it's about 73 nanoseconds so this is a
really easy way for you to just be
profiling your code
um not profiling sorry but measuring
your code
um there's other profilers as well but
they don't have good rebel integration
yet
so that's something that we should
definitely
that's weird
so let's
go back to julia
dev and then rappel there we go
so i'm writing down a bunch of projects
people want to pick them up
um issues to pick up
projects
um
native rebel
profile output
profiler output
we already
have
benchmark
why not also print
a
flame graph
in the rebel
right so if you've used um
the obvious code ide you can just do
like add prof viewer and then that will
inline to your vs code experience show
you
um where you can
show where you can
where
statistically your code is spending most
of its time
um
another really cool thing that people
might not know about it's possible to
save the record rebel commands to file
wow like five different people have
asked that
um yeah i'm gonna show it in just a
second
um
and
it's already saved to a file
basically um what's useful is
caching that
into a
actually you might be able to build it
in the last couple of minutes
all right um
there's this um
repo called the fix by michael slavinski
great name so if you ever type sine of
let's say 0.5
you're like oh sign isn't defined
and so i just get really angry and i
have type rf
and then it says oh did you mean sign
and i'm like yes i did and so it says
all right let me fix that with
sine of 0.5
so what's happened is that i have this
um
[Music]
um
i have this
uh please go away thank you
the fix lets you it will try and do like
a smart search
algorithm
for strings to the
nearest like
completable um
function or
constant you could typed in that you
probably mistyped and so
you define your
shortcut it can be a bit more obscene
than my double f
and so it's based on an actual package
that i can't probably pronounce on this
channel um
but you just type in double f whenever
you screw it up so instead if i said
su
quare three and i'm like hey that
doesn't exist oh
yes i meant that there we go instead of
typing the whole thing right
so that's really useful or at least for
showing off sometimes i don't even
remember and i just like retype it
anyways
um
uh
the textify the text file is incredibly
useful
um
the textify
lets you
indexify lets you output
latex code
from within julia
right
and what's really useful is when you
pair it up with clipboard
in fact i'm almost sure that the
latexify function
has a
quarks
to throw it into your
clipboard as well but the point is it
can be done
um and so if you ever need to type up a
table
you just do something like
the dexify
one two three four
and then
that's a really easy way to write a
matrix in latex right just type it in
julia and have the text if i figure it
out
and now that symbolics.jl is getting
more and more popular it's going to be a
pretty useful thing to do
package templates is how i built this
entire repo very quickly
you just type in t equals template and
then your username and then t my super
package and then this entire repo
structure right like all of this with
the ci workflows with the get ignore
with the license
the read me in the right place the test
files the source the workflows all of
that gets defaulted as part of package
templates so the easiest way for you to
set up being a pro junior developer just
use package templates
um
it's definitely a
really useful package to know about
all right
miscellaneous no uh unico plots or
rather
yeah eyeball is really cool
why oh it's because i changed julie
versions
so eyeball
what it has is a way to let you explore
the
[Music]
different fields of a really nested
struct
right
so you can say like all right what's
this args thing oh i don't know it's not
that interesting so maybe i can just
hide that
right
fields
that uh there's a uh
there you go
yes so you can expand or
minimize these
symbols
yeah with left to right
that's the easiest way to do it
you're like ah that's too much info
so you can just keep collapsing
with left and right
so
instead of being tap completing all the
way you can just say like hey what's
this like super
gnarly like let's say i don't know
this i o context that i had used
instead of trying to figure it out you
can just do i
i o
and then it will say like oh it those
are the things that are defined there
these are all booleans you can just
append
that's the max size the pointer and all
that stuff
and you can expand that if you're really
interested
showing items one through ten
hit e to expand there you go
awesome excellent package cannot
recommend enough
um very friendly to people who are part
of the
julia rebel
stan account gang
um hi let me read some of these
questions chanting the banner is it
possible hey mike how can i install
screen keys i think it's
apt
stalls
screen key on ubuntu so that's what
worked for me
um if your online should be in your
package manager mac doesn't have screen
keys i'm using windows oh sorry don't
know
for windows
um
yeah there's something equivalent a
screen keys you
but
it i i'm i won't know right now
uh terminal pager also really useful
don't do me like this oh my god
it's because
it's because i'm
i know why
because i didn't i'm not in the
environment
there we go
so this is a really big matrix
let's do it like
maybe
30
by
30 right
so this is a really big matrix
hm let's do 20.
yeah so
you can scroll with
l
or
j
and up and down okay that's not working
but
the point is that you can
if you ever get a data frame that's a
bit too big for what you're using you
can just use that
um
and it's very useful for
um
it's very useful for visualizing uh data
frames and navigating through the
columns just like wait what did that
thing say and just like
visually inspecting some of the values
um if you're wondering how a lot of
these packages handle their
printing
shenanigans it's
many of them call into this package
called abstract trees
and so that will
very easily let you
also
um
use
that um
use that interface so that you can have
really pretty
uh
pretty printing um there's these other
packages uh debugger cthulhu and snip
compile
which have to do with
stepping really deep into
the internals of julia debugger is like
the most accessible one
but the others work in a very similar
way in which you can do
enter parse int
and then you can do
like that
and so this is a debugger within your
terminal it's going to take a little bit
of time because
and so it will show you what you're
about to run if you don't know what you
want to do and it's like oh what's this
really funky thing you can type in
question mark and it will print out all
of the commands that you can type in
the really important ones are the ones
for adding a break point which will stop
the evaluation
at different points
um and then the next key
and and the one where you can
hit
the
comma
or not comma tilde so you can type in
now
um
super duper right and this is 100 and so
even as you're evaluating the function
you can
evaluate new julia code
as you're stepping in through that
function
so
you can go back to the debug mode and
step into the next call
step over with next step over that
step over and now it returns 123 which
was like what we wanted to
so that's one of your options for
debugging um cthulhu and compiled just
um i think snip compound does have a
rebel mode i'm pretty sure um
unico plots
i think i've shown
progress meter is really cool it will
let you very easily have
progress meters attached to for loops
so it's a really easy way of just having
a for for loop on your code
just attach a progress meter onto it
um
i don't want to talk a lot about term
but there's going to be a really cool
presentation on term at julicon i made
sure they were presenting
um they're going to demo some really
cool stuff so if you want to build out
this is one of the more fleshed out
terminal ui builders that are going to
be in julia i don't want to steal the
thunder but i'm really excited about it
um definitely check them out uh they'll
be giving a talk they've optimized the
code a bit
and so
yeah
um
do that
pretty tables if you don't want
something as
featureful as term you can just use
pretty tables
for some compact
for some compact um
representation of your types
you can customize it quite a bit but
it's very friendly it's very
easy to get set up with um
um finally uh this is one of the
projects that i most want to see in
julia it's a pluto rebel interface
so
you could probably use term to build
this but the point is
i
don't like spinning up a web browser for
using pluto but i do appreciate the
fact that you get like this model for
showing computation so term already has
a markdown renderer
um why not just like have the ability to
edit cells and move them around within
the pluto you you can call the pluto
engine because that's now a separate
part but somebody please build a pluto
rebel ui for the terminal
um pluto rebel yeah
uh that would be awesome
that would be really awesome i think it
would be probably a really good way to
get set up
um miscellaneous i didn't show this
before but
there's a part of the julia rebel itself
that's now terminal menus
um so if you're wondering how do you
even get started with this
um this used to be an outside library
and now it's part of julia it's called
terminal menus
um
and it's got oh the page is now there
so you can build a
veda menu
right
so let's see what does
using terminal
uh
menus
what no
using ripple
using rebel
terminal
menus right
terminal menus
so
radio menu
oh wow that's a lot of things so you can
have a
radio menu
of
let's say one
two three four
not that one
okay
yeah
right menu write a menu
all right but the point is you this is a
really easy way to just display a vector
of your options there we go yeah
radio
radio menu and then
abcd
there we go
and
what
request there we go
our request
radio menu
abcd
oh it's because
oh
and so
and
and it will return that will ever return
to the index right so this is just a
really bare bones way that you can just
ask for user input and have that thing
be spit back out
um right
um videos in terminal i try to set this
up
to
[Music]
um
play a video
i think this will work
um video terminal
yeah i couldn't get it to work but
there there's something with my computer
but there's definitely people who have
built facilities for
both capturing video from within your
julia ripple to um
displaying video right so this one is
um
so for example i did using kitty images
there we go okay terminal images
please
using
test images
please
so test
image and then
cameraman
and this should
oh lord all this for compilation
okay that's taken a bit unexpected
um
by the way another package in the vein
of that recommend is interactive code
search yes interactive code search is
cool i remember you asked about 2i
development julia terms seems to be it
yes i would definitely vouch for
turn to be the most full-fledged
output switch is reduced to the large
size
let the image show
um
so interactive errors isn't for everyone
but all right testing image camera man
all right didn't want to work it worked
before but
didn't work right now
so
there's also this demo of port audio
which is a
i'm
certain i'm basically certain that pluto
or the intro to computational thinking
course has this
uh has these notebooks where people take
a picture of their face and record their
voice and then do like fast fourier
transforms on it and the discrete
fourier transforms on the images um and
so i think it'd be pretty cool to just
have
a
10 lines of julia code that will
record your voice and then like plot it
and
show the fast fairy transform of it
that'd be really nice to show
in the
so in within like 10 lines of julia so
finally inductor dog strings so
okay
doctor
doc strings
i made this package a long time ago
ah doc strings
doctor
julia
all right i forgot
on youtube this game no no no
almost a year ago yeah cool
uh
to the language
so many
got this man
yeah i don't know why
there we go
uh and
that one
and so
i don't know why it's picking up a
gumball
split apply combined type tables
what the
all right using dr
duct strings right so in doctor doc
strings
there's a function called
um
uh history parser i think so pick and
copy
right
so this will show you a radio menu of
your previous
uh julia
histories so i could be like all right
what i really wanted was
um
this one
this one
and um let's say at the end
uh using dr dock strings right and then
i do done
and so this will say this was all copied
to your clipboard and so now if i paste
that
i have all that input in my julia ripple
so yeah
it's to answer your questions
uh let's um
add it it's
uh
dr doc strings
um
pick and
copy
that's the
method that people have been asking for
i wrote that because i needed that and i
got tired of copy pasting stuff there's
a bunch of other stuff in doctor doc
strings
um i think better
crystal has also also made like a
pick-and-copy rebel um
code that i basically hijacked um
i think it's based on that
interactive errors and abbreviated stack
traces are
probably the last packages that i get to
see
um
i get to talk about so
interactive errors
there we go
yeah i have it pulled up
so
cool about this is that you can get an
error
um
in the style of break loop debugging
and then you get different options for
what you want to do
right so you can have your
your desired uh text editor pulled up
for that um
you can roll back
you can do a bunch of things so let's
try and do
yeah
you can edit you can retry
and it's not for everyone to turn it on
but when you're
used to that
um
workflow that is really really cool
right so you can run oh you can run jet
on it now oh that's amazing
that's super cool
um
you can copy it to your clipboard
all that stuff so definitely
we should very
much interactive
bim
readme
interactive
i think they've already implemented the
debugging that i wanted
yes so it hijacks your errors and so
it's not
there's not i think there's not a way to
like turn it on per function where you
know it's like airing there
um but it'd be nice to
um
and a brief i think lastly we'll look at
abbreviated stack traces
i think also by michael heatherly
nope by a turbonic
um
so instead of getting this as a horrible
error message
you can get
this
where it's abbreviated
and so
that's another option
you can
set an environment flag for it
and this is one of yeah let's try that
one
using
brief
traces we're almost done
so if you do some
you get this error
oh
so now it's abbreviated
you can do error yeah so it binds it
so you get this horrible nasty stuff
or if you do
that
by the way there's an oh my repple
binding for
enable
autocomplete brackets
and you can set it to
false and so then you won't have stuff
like
um
asdf astr there we go
uh yeah i'll do that
because i find that super annoying
all my ripple enable autocomplete
brackets false
yeah
i think that's
basically all
everything that we have time for today
um
yeah i'm gonna
stop sharing my screen
but
i'm
yeah that's it
except for binary builder binary
builders are
um
it takes too long to run the
installation but maybe
uh people get the point
that this is really cool and that you
can help others with this
um
it's a wizard
in the rebel where you can guide people
through
helping set up third-party
codependencies
and that's very very useful and i've
used it to
build
that stuff for others so it will guide
you through how do you clone the repo
what the commit hash is what you want to
name it so it's just a series of
um interactive rebel statements where
you can make your
users become developers for other people
and i find that's really cool
okay so it says that it couldn't open
that stuff but you know you get this
really cool
uh rebel wizard saying e l f for the
appropriate bite marks
right and i'm going to close it there
um
and i think that's it on my part so yeah
i'm going to stop showing my screen
and we are going to go to oh my god
that's way too much
oh
okay
way too personal way to go uh let's run
some brands
um stream yard overlay
uh
chili con 2020
yeah all right show that
oh hide that
all right
yup
well that's it for me um
thank you everyone
um
five this workshop must review and learn
from i'll be watching the video so what
i will be doing is trying to
cut down the
quick parts of each section of the
workshop so that people can just watch
five minutes at a time because nobody
ever watches an entire workshop back
again like there's like maybe 20 people
over a year that do it but having
bite-sized like rebel
um
nuggets
it's very useful to go back to like oh
what was that um shortcut thing how did
you do that like what does it look like
um
and i'll i'll keep updating the workshop
i don't think it's just a one and done
thing because people are going to keep
building really cool stuff there's going
to be a lot more documentation than just
like a really long read me
um this was just the easiest way to show
it to people
and share it with people
and
also doing the live coding for me
that was a fun workshop thank you thanks
a lot thanks miguel had a fun learned a
lot ricardo rios
um
i have to watch workshop videos from
last julycon still am i to do this yeah
everyone has like a really long to-do
list with julie conn videos but um
that's part of the game i guess it's
that's a good problem to have i guess
um
thanks for the awesome workshop says
filippo de nada
um
cheers people hope you all enjoyed hope
you're getting better at your rebel we
ended up with 63 people here awesome
um
yeah
all right
let's
end the broadcast
let's do it
or unless anyone has any questions wait
i haven't checked the discord
um
so whenever i wish to change our output
help for errors interactive errors
previous factors to default it's an easy
way to switch through all these during a
rebel session i think that's the part of
the global flags that they were setting
in the environment
um
thank you ricardo rios
thanks to everyone in spanish latin
america don't forget we're i'm going to
have a julia
birds of a feather in spanish and i'm
going to give a julie con watts talk so
if you think this was all the cool parts
of the ripple you might run into some
monsters and some really unexpected
parts and that's going to be the julicon
what talk
so stay posted for that one
cheers